i was on diets from five
uh until basically until
um until i just started telling my
parents to off
uh which was like 14. um
and uh i was you know
it was uh there was a
sense of um wrongness my first
my first idea of self you know you're a
little kid
and there's no idea that like oh this
body
like there was no awareness of it the
first bit of awareness that i had about
my body was that it was wrong uh
and and so and then i was just
and then it was just constantly
reaffirmed through
[Music]
you know my whole family would go
macrobiotic but really
it was just because they they thought
this macro by
you know and you can name any diet um
atkins at some point in the 80s and and
fit for life and it there were adele
davis books which she was like the first
diet person i
was ever truly like here we're gonna
read this book together and you're seven
and i'm like
okay um but there was just a constant
feeling of being off from like
five on uh
and so when i just kind of
got sick of it and was like i'm not
gonna conform to
what i'm not gonna do what you tell me
to do anymore
um you know i went
like like a runaway train
down the road away from the goals they
were setting for me
wow because you know it's those
developmental stages it's like that
young
five six seven that little
that i remember you're short you're you
know
you're you're not smart you're those
things stick with you no matter how
smart
you get or how tall you get you always
remember for some reason i wish i could
just stop that little
from thinking these things that you
weren't good enough you weren't smart
enough you weren't whatever
but you're saying ultimately that at
that young age
you're like what's wrong with me
ultimately like i
and and does that carry with you
throughout your adulthood like even
though you're in great shape now you
look great you feel great
do you still think back i'm still that
kid
you know it's a very um tricky thing
because i don't know
i can i can mentally work myself through
it today
but there is always kind of my
my gut reaction to myself in the mirror
or a photograph or anything like that
is always kind of discussed and
and as of today i can definitely stop
that because i know that's a dark road
if i allow myself to sit in that so i
take time and i find
something about myself that i'm not
disgusted by
and i build on that and then i feel a
little bit better
and but yeah there there there's no like
true escape from there's no like
off switch where it just goes away i
haven't found that for myself